let's jump to this story and we'll get
into it we got this from reuters
annual pro-gun event at virginia fizzles
in wake of u.s capital siege they say
only a few dozen gun rights activists
converge in the virginia state capitol
on monday for an annual demonstration
that typically draws thousands with this
year's protests dampened by tensions in
the wake of the january 6
siege in the capital now i'm not
entirely sure they're right about this
sometimes what happens with these these
news stories when they talk about these
events this was published on at 6 15 a.m
but we actually have this tweet from
ryan devereaux
from 5 37 pm where you can clearly see
there's black panthers out there there's
proud boys
and there's boogaloo boys and the
interesting thing about it is
ryan devro tweets heard a 20 year old
boogaloo boy call a passing group of
proud boys quote
boot licking statist cucks the proud
boys dismissed the boogas anarchists
the original black panther party just
seemed happy to be there
so i guess look they're they're i don't
know if it's the same event maybe
it must be different i i thought it was
the same event so maybe i'm wrong about
that
but there were still people coming out
and protesting in various in various
areas
what i find interesting about this story
is just how the boogaloo boys are an
entity unto themselves
they're basically just anarchists
so uh or libertarian types and growing
growing in in popularity
too you know so there's more and more
people who are starting to identify with
with
that but let's just throw the whole
government out but but you know
it's it's because i mean do you know
anybody who's happy with government
right now
no and right for good reason i mean you
can't blame these people for being
frustrated now i might not agree with
the hawaiian shirts and all that um yeah
right
but i mean we're we're rapidly
approaching that point where the whole
system is just broken like we're just
gonna have to throw the whole thing out
you know like it's
what did i mean thomas jefferson was he
the one who said every 200 years
you've got to like you know purge and
recycle or whatever well this group is
definitely interesting because
it's hard to kind of nail them down just
a few
months ago the mainstream media was
talking about them being right wing
extremist but
they they are hyper critical of donald
trump they are hyper critical of
government officials
we saw in one particular state one of
the boogaloo boys had a trans flag
another person stood next to and was
with a black lives matter person and it
looked like they were all together
but another thing we really have to
understand here a lot of this is over
hyped by the mainstream media
because if you remember just a few days
ago we were hearing news reports
fbi warnings total fear-mongering
paranoia massive armed rallies happening
this weekend
all throughout the united states and all
the major capitals and what did we get
crickets
no like three guys five guys standing
around
five guys in new hampshire a couple guys
in virginia and now we had another rally
today in virginia that was separate out
of shape guys
well some of them are out of shape some
of them are you know just look like they
you know they have shapes they're just
not
yeah but but but today in virginia we
saw the biggest rally and we saw a bunch
of groups bunch of individuals
uh and this was the biggest one but
again everything was it was very
peaceful everything was
it was very calm they they came armed no
one got shot no one got hurt
thank goodness for that and it's the
opposite of everything that we've been
hearing on the mainstream media
about how there's a bloodbath coming and
they're still fear-mongering about this
at the u.s capitol
that literally i don't know why no one's
talking about this but it looks like the
the washington
dc is literally under occupation right
now and no one's
trying to even talk about green zones
and police checkpoints
and and and what in the world is
happening in the center
of the united states 25 000. interesting
interesting number that's ten times the
amount of troops that we have in iraq
i read that today we have about we have
about twenty five hundred to three
thousand in iraq
we have more troops we have twenty five
thousand and they're asking for thirty
why and hundreds of nypd officers
literally went down today to add
more security and assistance yes nypd
sent out from
the boogaloo boys exactly well this is
this is this is the thing
there's so much this is what i did a
video on today specifically on the we
are change channel about this
active national security fear paranoia
state
that is absolutely ridiculous and there
and and when you see the mainstream
media coverage it looks like there's
going to be a huge conflict
but the only thing i'm seeing is people
saying hey stay home stay away from this
there might be a potential for a false
flag get away from there don't go there
but we're still being told by the
mainstream media that there's going to
be hell to pay
you know those 25 000 national guardsmen
all are being vetted to make sure that
they don't support donald trump two oil
changes yes
they're literally doing loyalty testing
there were some reports that the
democrats wanted to make sure that
any like the national guard who voted
for trump they'd vet or remove
weren't there i don't i don't know how
true that is i've seen that no no no
this was this originally came out from a
congressman
demanding this and now schumer and
pelosi officially came out
saying we want the dod to vet everyone
there
and we have the acting defense security
chief coming out and saying
there's no threat of an insider attack
like we've been hearing on the
mainstream media again but i mean
specifically
like are the democrats saying we want to
know who voted for trump or are they
saying
we want security assessments because i
heard reports that they were concerned
about national guardsmen who voted trump
as the starting point to actually look
into their backgrounds
yes and and that nancy pelosi came out
and i think said that and then they also
requested
and and i don't know if it ever went
through but i know that
somebody from congress requested that i
think it was nancy pelosi as well
that they'd be unarmed yeah i think i
heard that a lot of them have been on
arm
there's a lot of photos of them without
magazines in their rifles so
so yeah right they want to disarm them
which is interesting who armed them in
the first place
yeah but this is this is what do you
mean twenty five thousand unarmed troops
who sent them no no but this is weird
this is weird
why are there twenty five thousand
soldiers in dc anyway
who put them there was it the democrats
uh nancy pelosi saying
we're worried about this vet them and
disarm them
i don't think she's the one who put him
there i don't think the democrats the
one who who demanded 25
000 is this trump
well there's the way i would assume the
way i heard it explained is just another
vague term
saying these were federally mandated
soldiers that were sent there by the
federal government that's the vague
biggest language so that would be
commander-in-chief
then there was there was some retired
general said we haven't had this much
security since abraham lincoln
so so someone did this but it's just my
understanding is that it's the acting
secretary of defense who who deploys the
federal
national guard in the dc you know the
federal jurisdiction and he's a trump
guy
so is trump the one who's like send all
of the troops
i don't know man because you know the
conspiracy theories are going crazy on
both the left and the right
the right is saying that trump has
created a prison that the democrats will
have to walk into in order to inaugurate
biden
and the left is saying because they're
that stupid yeah well yeah right
that's the conspiracy theory but the
left has basically the same conspiracy
theory
that donald trump is gonna box the
democrat
it's it's it's they believe very much
similar almost like one person's making
both of them up and just sending them
through the message board and stuff
yeah one one side's going donald trump's
gonna do it hooray
the other side's going then he goes
through the left and goes donald trump's
gonna do it oh no
this is from uh the babylon b not
newsguarded
it's a satire website the most popular
president in history to be inaugurated
in secret behind giant wall guarded by
thousands of soldiers
yes which as as fake as that is it's
not it's also true by the numbers i mean
he got the most votes of any president
well another thing to really consider
here is that before the raid on the
capitol we had warnings from the fbi the
nypd the capitol police that something
major was going to happen at the capitol
and then what happened they were mainly
unprepared now we're getting
no specific warnings the acting defense
secretary said there's no intelligence
of any upcoming attack or threat
but yet they're over prepared that's
that's there's a government
there's a conspiracy theory too little
too late too much too late excuse me
this is this is the ongoing conspiracy
theory let me just start by saying dude
like january 20th is gonna come and go i
really don't see anything happening i'll
admit this is all very weird stuff
we are well outside the confines of
what's considered normal
but the conspiracy theory right now is
that donald trump
needed an excuse to mobilize the
national guard in dc
in an unprecedented manner and if he
just did this
the democrats would scream he's staging
a coup trump deploying 25 000
fully armed with authorization freeze of
lethal force
into dc for no reason the democrats
would be like this is insane
trump's staging a coup but what happened
was trump supporters thrown into the
capital
the democrats demanded securian were
shocked so then trump went
okay and got his 25 000. i don't believe
it's on purpose
you know this is this is the current
iteration of the conspiracy and i these
q people are
you know posting online saying just you
you'll wait and see trump's gonna do
something trump's not gonna do anything
nothing's gonna happen
biden's gonna be president four years of
let's wait and see right right right any
day now they choose but that's
that's what that's that's their current
conspiracy i will say
it's easy to understand why they believe
it because it is because none of it
makes any sense
right it's really strange what's going
on it's a james bond movie so
well so some some other people i've uh
you know have been posting that they
think
it's just the democrats an excuse it's
the establishment saying oh no look what
we had to do because of trump supporters
more funding
and we needed to because what would have
happened if they weren't there
more money more security more spying etc
you know what it looks like to me
like the start of a police state
where there's part of there's a there's
a constant
level of fear like you were just talking
about in the media where
there's always some impending doom upon
you so
you have to listen to what the
government says yeah there's always some
restriction on movement
there's always some looming threat that
you have to be defended
against and what a way to kick off four
years of that
with 25 000 troops in the nation's
capital in an
unprecedented rollout of military force
during an inauguration where
nobody is going to show up you know i
i've mentioned this a million times so
for those that are listening forgive me
but i want to say it for for for you ian
because we've never talked about it
that what people don't realize when it
comes to staging a coup they move
they imagine it'll be like a movie where
there's going to be like trump going
order the troops to stop biden make me
president and the troops just listen
when in reality a coup actually looks
very simple it's not the soldiers have
any idea what's going on
it would just be their commanding
officer or the pentagon saying hey
go surround the white house lock it down
there's some security threats and then
they would
if donald trump wanted to stage a
military coup and use the military to
seize power and stop the inauguration
they wouldn't tell the national guard to
do that they would tell them
stand here and don't let anyone pass
that's it
so i think if there was a real potential
for a coup
it would look exactly like this exactly
the soldiers just being like i don't
know i was told to stand here yep
you're not wrong and a lot of the
soldiers that are being interviewed
they're asked what are you doing here
what are you protecting
and uh according to michael tracy and
the reporting he's doing down there
he's like well one of them just told me
i don't know i'm just doing what i'm
told
and that's what a lot of the scary
teachers are doing there's a meme going
around that i tweeted right now that i
think
uh hits the nail on the head with our
conversation here and it shows
all the troops sleeping together in the
capital not social distancing
and and the headline is if 25 000 troops
can do this
you can do this and below it is a
picture of four people having a nice
meal at a restaurant
so i think that's another thing that
people really need to kind of understand
here
if we're going through this huge
pandemic we're going through this huge
health scare why is the government
punishing you for for trying to be in a
gym or in a restaurant meanwhile there's
so many troops
sleeping on a marvel sleeping on the
marble floor why would the government
risk the national guard during a
pandemic yeah okay i get it you want to
protect the elderly right well
the national guard is one of our first
lines of defense
cramming them all in the capitol
building sleeping
each other capital was attacked from the
air by a foreign nation on the
inauguration
part all there that's my partner brought
that up today it's a very good point why
would you put that many
people in in harm's way if you're cons
if you're
if you're so if you're so afraid of of
this looming threat
why would you put such a massive forces
in harm's way they're using them like a
fence to to keep the water out to keep
the flooding or they're trying to build
a wall of humans to
to protect but we're in a drought it's
because
the elites use your children as cannon
fodder
or sand bags in this scenario i guess
like they're probably gonna put them on
every street
and and every block corner and that's
why there's so many of them they have
history they have authorization for use
of lethal force
why wait with what though it's the fact
that
they're really they're full they're full
kitted yeah okay yeah
all of them had their guns and magazines
right pelosi was magazines and boats
take the magazines out and take them
away
okay but some are still armed or they
they
last i checked they were fully kitted
okay they were given authorization for
use of lethal force
and the democrats were like nah we don't
want them to have guns like this
so i don't know exactly where we're at
right now but why was that ever a thing
yeah what what's going on
yeah you know what i mean another thing
to consider is if you're in the military
your commanding officers and your
politicians don't give a damn about you
and if they tell you to sleep on the
marble floor surrounded by
hundreds of people during a pandemic
you're gonna do it because you're gonna
do what you're told
and i think i just saw today that
finally there was some cots delivered
but most of them are still sleeping and
using the few limited restrooms
inside of the capitol building i mean
imagine being a soldier and just like
yep you're going to be inside the
capitol
for what what this paranoia this fear
that's that's again
totally made up not a real security
threat
when they had the security threats they
didn't listen to them now there's no
security threats according to them
officially
but yet we're still going through this
huge security theater
in order to i i think it's a it's a
larger virtual signal for the bigger
police state that they're trying to
to boast about in everyone's face
so here's a story from the 14th national
guard at capital authorized to use
lethal force and aftermath of mob
they say on january 12 2021 national
guardsmen were given authorization to be
armed in support of the u.s capitol
to protect the u.s capitol and
individual members of congress and their
staff
according to a statement from the dc
guard they go on to say a defense
official confirmed the authorization
includes permission for guards
guard troops to use lethal force
so they're there there's pictures of
them carrying their guns
and i believe the national guard they
have full auto don't they don't they
have selected fire
yeah of course that's i'm just i'm just
kind of weirded out by the whole thing
we're all going to be watching or we're
all supposed to be watching this
inauguration and you're going to see
this
military-style inauguration this police
state
totarian like it just it screams or well
i mean it's
it's all of it yeah it's very it's very
very very peculiar and
the the crazy part is the the media just
just ratchets the fear we get no
explanation as to why we get
the only information that we get are
from the few journalists who actually
put some good stuff
out but it's just be afraid to shut up
the mainstream media is showing no
apprehension against an actual police
state an actual lockdown
an actual you know checkpoint set up
green zone set up the militarization of
the
cities of the of the entire country's
capital
and yet no muck breaking no real
journalism no
no no questions about it at all that's
another thing
that that has you thinking because they
were warning they were screaming about
fascism about totalitarianism coming
under donald trump
but now it's coming in as it looks very
symbolically
under joe biden right in front of our
face and they're marching around
lock and locking everything down the
barbed wire set up like they're
literally about to face a
horde of zombies that's it's it's like
it's like watching dayz
happening right now it's like it's like
that's what they're preparing for i
don't know maybe there's something else
happening that we don't know about
i don't think so but i think this is a
larger virtue signal
i think this is this is the them saying
look at us
look how powerful we are don't mess with
us because we have
all these police officers all these
national guard that will do whatever we
tell them to do and they will back us
and you can't fight us because of look
how many soldiers
we have behind us which is that's what's
up perfect follow-up to the
to the capitol which is like you know
they had this little incident at the
capitol that they've blown
hugely out of proportion based on a lot
of half truths and and
misinformation and then now they turn
around a couple weeks later and say
try it again it's like you tickle the
nose of the dragon and the whole body
goes flailing
like they went in and they they got the
congress people like
aoc said she was afraid for her life she
said she narrowly escaped death yeah so
they're they're
twisted with fear right now yes do you
see the video of the shaman walking in
walking
chambers with the mall cop behind him
and there's a
there's a guy sitting down on the phone
and the shaman guy goes like hey man
good to see you he's like oh that guy is
bleeding
and the cops like you need medical
attention he goes i'm fine and then the
mall cop guy goes
any chance i could get you guys to leave
and they were like we're leaving we're
leaving
and the one guy goes don't worry man i'm
making sure nobody messes with anything
he's like all right thanks because this
is like the sacred most sacred place
that like an insurrection of a bunch of
like just dumb people standing around
i get it storming the capital was dumb
but you saw the videos of people cops
letting people in
oh yeah i mean it it was all over with
it it was basically a guided tour
yeah a lot of the cop there's one video
where the cops like disagree with it but
agree with your right to protest
there's a war right passing me let's
amen there was a zero percent chance of
insurrection there was a zero percent
chance of them being able to overthrow
overturn the government so calling it a
coup d'etat is absolutely disingenuous
and it's an absolute lie
i love how they're trying to act like
there's ever a possibility that
occupying a building would overthrow the
government
like it's it's not 1600s anymore you
know what i mean like
they they they storm the vault they
control the government papers now
they're the government but no their word
works people were in that building as
far as i know so
if they if they had wanted to go in
there and destroy those people they
probably could have and that still
wouldn't change anything so there's the
line of succession
and then you know look if god forbid
they actually did horrible things to
members of congress yeah
it wouldn't they're not gonna it would
just be indictments there would be
charges of sedition but it never
happened like where a bunch of congress
people were killed
in a day in a riot in the united states
that's never what i'm saying is that
there's
there was no scenario where this was an
insurrection okay i mean
hold on i guess maybe you could call it
that if it was like
the the i don't know it's a major
stretch
well i don't think that was their
intention attempted insurrection maybe
but there was never a possibility
it would do anything there's zero
possibility the government was
anywhere in danger of being overthrown
period yeah trump has no institutional
power
mike pence was even against him so when
we're talking about the chances here
let's be real here let's be honest yes
there's some bad actors yes there are
some violent people let's call it out to
you know
however you may want to call it out but
but when we learn
when we're looking at everything this is
this is just security theater in a
hyperbolic response to it
that that is definitely disproportionate
to say the least from my own personality
the question is who sent the the armed
guards there
the democrats do it because they
genuinely believe as a threat or they
want the optics well they seem to be
kind of upset by it
and the national guard follows the
orders of trump for now there's two more
days actually
i think we got about a day and a half
maybe you start the countdown
yeah many immediate many media
organizations have
they literally have countdowns can we
get
just before even coming on the show i
saw a friend that was flying into dc
and she talked about how after coming
out of the tsa
she had to go through two other personal
screenings
they looked through all of her personal
possessions in her
bags and there was police officers
literally at the gate watching everyone
come in
so the the security for even flying into
washington dc is
absolutely utterly ridiculous so
um again no threat as as so far that we
know of that's legitimate so so what is
going on here
well so we we have the countdown we have
it right here on the it's a daily mail
right on top 38 hours 54 minutes
uh now 53 minutes and we also have the
story
biden blocks trump's bid to lift ban on
visitors from the uk
brazil and europe and says he will
strengthen travel restrictions
dashing hopes of millions who haven't
been able to fly to the us since march
all those people who voted for biden
thinking they were gonna get something
good out of this
it's not gonna happen it's only going to
be worse under joe biden maybe not
totally
i think he's gonna diminish uh student
loan debt at least he says he's going to
there's no diminishing student loan debt
and paying for someone's bad choices and
mistakes are they not just not paying
back the
the loan agencies they're paying the
investors the loan agencies
gets their money the bankers always get
their money dude if they're going to tax
us to pay
the loans that's exactly right that's
exactly that's how government works
don't pay them back man that's insidious
that they're charging kids interest
it doesn't work you have to not not in
america it doesn't work like that every
every banker always always gets their
due yeah that's that's the first rule of
of finance in america
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time